live we're live hello good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel we're with Young Harris howy
Young Harris middle-aged yes
Aaron yeah I got a year on you old
ancient crusty F while you were on break
I was the oldest one on screen because I
I think we figured out that I'm still
about a year or so older than Jay
jez gez you actually look much much
older than that so that's why he said
middle age just to make sure you know
baby face baby face baby
face this [__] off I give you a run on
baby face
too I can't grow up D so I'm not even
gonna start that one I'm very jealous
when you come for Comicon I'll shave and
give you some don't worry oh going to
give me some give me some water that
sounds awesome let's do that is this how
we're starting again I didn't open oh my
God I get all the [__] for this you guys
are running
around right so we are gonna be
talking his mouth's moving but I can't
hear anything you're saying Aaron I
can't hear you would so what' you say
Aaron was Aaron's mouth was moving but I
couldn't hear what he was saying but
anyway let's move on so um we are both
talking to sooka we are talking toxic
fan base we are talking and that's going
to be sci-fi across the board but
particularly
um with a lot of the stuff around a
sooka so first of all we're just GNA go
around I've even seen
Ahsoka even I've seen it um and even I
quite enjoyed it so just generally
speaking what we what did we think we'll
go stormmy and we'll go we'll go that
way around so um stormmy what do you
think of it are we're talking about the
series in general or just the last
episode no the series in general I love
the [__] out of it I mean you know it
was the the the worst thing about it was
I watched the lap at last episode and I
thought God that was a great episode and
then I read in the comments somewhere
that Ray Stevenson had passed that he
had died back in May and then I was
crestfallen because I how you found out
yes I'm sorry comments off of uh
Facebook or Tik Tok I had no idea you
because I really I don't read a lot of
these uh fan websites because they'll a
lot of times there spoilers and I want
to enjoy the film as it is and that's
come to bite me in the ass once really
bad um I went to go see this um it was
at the Kabuki theater in San Francisco
the San Francisco Cinema Society was
showing a film called uh bottles shock
and there was this one actor there the
lead actor that I got to talk to and uh
you know was talking about the film and
his acting style and how he you know got
prepared for it well that guy was Chris
Pine and I had no idea he had just
wrapped filming on Star Trek no clue I
we just talked about wine and in the
movie bottle shot because I was because
that's what I get for not following this
stuff so that Ray Steven has died in
comments from something on Facebook I
think and I really fell in love with him
during Rome
Ro he was awesome if you haven't seen
Rome that was on it was an HBO series
God he was great he was just it was
awesome but anyway I love Ahsoka the um
the introduction of uh thrawn when you
know the the the rundown Imperial that
the Smurf dude that the giant Smurf
right Smurf dude yeah yeah yeah I just
thought was evil villain opening ever I
just I love Ahsoka you know and it
really hurts my heart and I go on
Twitter um and just see people [__]
about oh it's so woke how can anyone
stand don't get ahead of yourself we're
coming to that okay fine I likeed it end
of s coming back to it um all worked up
now I'd love to know Le like what what
in the bits particular did I mean
because for me um all the the lightsaber
battles would highlights that I don't
normally say that because I find them a
little bit drawn out a little bit boring
but I thought in sooka fantastic
particularly the chick pain aoka I
thought she was fantastic she moves like
a dancer I just thought it was stunning
Aaron what did you
think numbers wise overall I give the
entire series an eight and a half um I
would say half of it was fire and the
other half was good but not great like
pretty much four episodes of
each it was better than Mandalorian for
that because of Mandalorian has some
really stinkers
better than season three of Mando for
sure like it I'm still having trouble
deciding between it and Mando season two
but I'm still I'm leaning Ahsoka for the
best Disney plus Star Wars show
currently that is high price high
price Harris what did you think
they best best Disney show so far best
best live action show so far well that's
what I was that's what I was waiting for
that's what I was like this this Dave
Fon God Emperor Dave Fon is going to
bring it to us I grew up on Clone Wars I
grew up on Rebels as like my adulthood
started kind of we got the the finished
Clone Wars which was kind of beautiful
and kind of like oh well my childhood's
complete now thanks Dave you know
uh this was underwhelming as a season as
a as as an opening uh I understand Dave
filon I I love the way he slow Burns
storytelling and and he puts a lot of
puzzle pieces to unravel later on in his
stories in that first season which can
make those first Seasons feel typically
more childlike CU he indulges like a
younger protagonist typically that did
not happen here and I don't think there
were many puzzle pieces to unlock either
as as much as like I I will there's a
reason I'm calling him God Emperor Dave
Fon he's the creative director over at
lucasfilm I love the guy's work avatar
The Last Airbender Clone Wars Rebels etc
etc
etc this was that that it just wasn't
what it should have been it just wasn't
I don't dislike it I know I'm sounding
like I'm I'm disliking yet but my
expectations were so high that they just
weren't met and and that that that's
from the little kid with with bright
eyes just going into it with an open
mind and just excited for everything who
literally finished Rebels by episode
three of Ahsoka for my rewatch like
every puzzle piece was there for me and
it just it just didn't do it the way I
wanted it to at the end of the day I'm
going to say there are some bits in this
I overall I'm going to say I like this
series overall I thought it was was
great um I preferred Andor and I
preferred the couple of series of
mandelorean I even probably preferred
Boba Fett this isn't massively high up I
love the chick they got playing the SOA
I thought she was
amazing um and she really everything
that raised up because of that but space
whales are stupid the first two episodes
are incredibly forgettable it was better
when it went over to um the other in the
other Galaxy and if you haven't seen the
animated movies the Animated Series you
need to do a lot of reading and research
to understand what the bloody hell is
going on so those are quite serious
downsides for me never watching I've
never watched Clone Wars I've never
watched these things I'm not as big a
Star Wars fan as you guys um so overall
yeah I liked
it hyperspace whales are
dumb and I'm sorry it was dumb there's
there's there's bits there's a a few
bits like that in Star Trek recently and
it's just dumb the way they executed
them were dumb if you were to watch
Rebels I know it's a lot to go back and
do all the homework just to watch the
One season of
Television then it makes perfect sense I
know that's not an excuse that's really
not an
excuse but like like a lot of the things
I think that I I hold issue with it's
it's pacing and execution for this
season as a whole and Star Wars
generally we talked a lot about that on
chill in the basement uh yesterday
evening um it's just that their pacing
screwed up right now and it is messing
with their ability to execute I think
and if the pgle were given just a little
bit more uh depth they would have made a
lot more sense because they are they're
a really intriguing kind of
thing I think they got the pace in much
much better and the overall story and
stuff made more sense than Mandalorian
season 3 Mandalorian season three was oh
yeah bad it it was not
good
sorry I I I agree with you up until
episodes seven and eight they lost the
pacing in Ahsoka the last two episodes
and it I think it's really hurting the
series as a whole and the way people are
going to look back at
it well why was it Eight Episodes over
10 thought would it originally announced
be 10 episodes or was it always gonna be
eight I think it was always eight but
I'm not 100 on that it's always be isn't
that Star Wars they do eight quite a lot
don't they
most of the time yeah the only really
the only really long one is uh Andor
that was 12 is that
12 see now I found Andor incredibly
boring in places but I find All Star
Wars incredibly boring in places um I I
even watch the original trilogy and I'm
G to duck because shit's gonna get
thrown at me yeah I find the original
trilogy boring in
places are we
okay okay um
it it's I mean God it's boring um but I
I I appreciate the the class and Andor I
loved as overall I'm going overall I
thought it was great but in places I
could have just took a nap and I
wouldn't have missed anything so what do
you think about the Goram
Anders what the the gormagander from
Star they were space
whales what Goram yeah they were space
whales in Star Trek why do you think
about that
I mean they were in commanders are they
remember uh Harry M came hiding oh god
oh don't [__] throw original series
at me I have no [__]
clue I haven't watched the original
series for 25 years and it's not my fa
there were some space in Star
Trek was a space Acorn he was basically
shaped like an acorn but he's a Spaceman
and there are space um
um bloody jellyfish all over the place
Star Trek all over the place um but no
space whales remember station is kind of
a jelly fishy thingy yeah but I don't
remember that um but but yeah
no it's it's just I I I I'm okay with
these stuff living in
space but H
whales seems a bit silly they do much
much faster than anything else though as
well they can go between galaxies
apparently makes no sense you're
stupid that's how we learned how to
hyperspace travel yeah you know it's
what inspired humans or the Rotton
Empire or the Zeo whoever it may have
been way back in the day to actually
travel they have a hyperspace H fin it
it showed that wait a second maybe we're
not stuck where we are maybe we should
develop something to go out into the
Stars that's right well knows best look
Hey look it's sci-fi at the end of the
day it's supposed to be incredible um
but I just sometimes and even watching
Star Trek watching Stargate watching
anything I actually like um other than
star I don't particularly um I find you
know sometimes you just go what the [__]
is that um and and that was what the
[__] is that moment um but you know
anyway what's next for Star Wars
Harrison's
Aaron uh skeleton cre in
January yeah are ref for sure that it's
January or were we just talking about it
yesterday okay okay I've I've been I've
been seeing I've been seeing on the twit
X that um that tenative dat's been put
out I don't know how I'm G to make
it but that's that's they said that
what's the exact they said they're
aiming for a January 2024 release for
that okay I see that's Skeleton Crew
Skeleton Crew the Jude Law and the
children one the Jude Law Series
yeah Jamie's face immediately I [__]
hate
Jud why Jude
Law he's a
bellend he can't act he always just
plays Jude Law the only thing I've ever
seen him in that I didn't hate like hate
is um the Robert Robert Danny Jr Holmes
movies they did and he played Dr Watson
oh yeah he ruined fun like Pier L people
are like [__] that but those movies were
awesome I L it I loved it it was more
like the com based on the comic book
series rather than the Arthur K doy
Series so a lot of people did go crazy
that dude that the dude that plays
marity I love that guy yeah he's great
hey uh they've got Sherlock Holmes 3 in
pre-production and he's gonna be Dr
Watson
again
yep yeah guy Richie's back baby he's
made he's actually made a couple of good
films and he's got the money to make
shock Holmes 3 a couple of good films
guy Rich's been doing nothing but good
he had a
l it that King Arthur film was pretty
bloody bad that was a decade ago yeah
there was a little back to me cons what
did I just
say that was a
law he got back to
he's been hitting as of recent it's been
great my favorite working director maybe
right now he's G back to doing some
stuff that he's used to isn't he though
that that the last couple of films he's
done have been bloody really good really
really like two films a year out the
last two or three years and all of them
have been super fun they been so much
fun you got remember my
age I really liked him in Sky Captain in
the World of Tomorrow I really did like
him that movie
no loved it no it was
awful it was awful Lyn's cap perfectly
executed
line Sky Captain in the World of
Tomorrow is genuinely one of the worst
films ever made loved it it's it looks
awful amazing it was badly executed it
was badly acted even antelina jool Lee
was awful in it it was it was
awful love I'll stor me I've lost I've
lost faith in you now mate if I had seen
that that was the kind of movie that I
would have just like [__] my pants if
I'd seen it as a kid you know because I
mean it was just the I I thought it was
really a beckon back to um a lot of the
Sci-Fi you saw back in the day I mean
like so I watched a Forbidden Planet
this week for the first time in like 20
years and and the aesthetic that was in
Sky Captain and forbidden planet was
damn near the same except Sky Forbidden
Planet was in cinemascope and
color but yeah it had the the feelings
of an early 50 Adventure movie I really
did like it it's and from that really
was well executed it was supposed to
look like those classic 19 like like
1950s Flash Gordon yeah that sort of
thing that's what it was supposed to
look like I just think they maybe did a
little bit too of a good job because it
looked like a 1950s B movie but bit too
much um and it was maybe a little bit
ahead of its time it was awful Jude Law
is a bad man he's a bad human being and
um I'd punch him in the face if I met
him so we're we're not getting him on
here anytime soon right no no I just
don't like him as act I just don't think
he's a particular good actor I just
think he plays Jude Law and I just don't
like him but I love him in um what he
also like Mark
wurn next
my wife loves Mark Walberg my wife
thinks Mark wallberg is the B um I I
he's a bit wooden as well but he has
made fil how are you gonna let her get
away with that dude you're a gator it's
got to be M MOA you must convince her
she she doesn't she's not a big fan of
go after Beefcake she needs to go after
Stargate Beefcake well she's not into
that but I'll fight you for Jason M MOA
I'll fight you for Jason I think Mar is
a better um d as a like a he's a a
businessman than he is a um actor I'll
put it that way he chooses good films
and he makes he produces a lot of no
he's even produces good films he's not
particularly great in them well who do
you think should have played his part in
GAA J LW Harris Harris somebody H there
you go Harris has got a job in remake
please he'd been 12 years old haris
should do everything Harris is my answer
to everything who should be in the new
Stargates
Iris I'll take
it we say it enough we will Manifest
this get oh yes manifest me a pain J how
many different ways how many different
ways can we make Harris look so before
they kill him like he's he's gonna be a
redir everye different kinds of makeup
on him and kill him every time he's
gonna be Stargates
Kenny I'm okay with that I'm totally
okay with that
please Harris is always the answer we
did want to talk a little bit about the
toxic fan base though that um stormmy
you you you
mentioned
so just just tell I know you said you
were looking through bunch of comments
and the week and it really got you riled
up because you then you sent us a bunch
of them um so
what what got you riled up what what
triggered you
stormy well it's the the thing that
really just
um has me shaking my head
is the amount of hate that a lot of
these franchises generate including uh
Ahsoka before anybody is before the
before anything is released and
sometimes even before some of the promo
shots are released or the one sheet is
made you know it's just there's this
group in social media you know trolls
that will latch onto a new franchise and
try to absolutely destroy
it you know and it it's just and then
they continue on you know um essentially
doing negative marketing and it wouldn't
surprise me that
um that somebody has hired a uh Ad
Agency to run um negative comments you
know slews of bots on Twitter or
wherever to just defame and just
denigrate these shows before they ever
get a chance to find their feet you know
and so the so then the uh the popular
opinion is all that show's got is going
to suck so everybody thinks the show is
going to suck and their predisposition
to think the show is going to suck
before anyone has seen the first
cut and that just really disturbs me I
mean essentially the actors are fighting
propaganda that's out of their
control I have heard a couple of people
say that ahoko is woke I know some
people say everything's woke honestly
you could have a movie I don't know you
can have a Rambo movie who just runs
around and murders everybody for like 90
minutes and somebody goes woke go um
he he murdered more men than he did
women something I don't know um I'm
being thingy because I I I before people
get angry at me I actually think there
is an argument to say that some stuff
out there and I hate the term you all
know this I keep telling you I hate it
but um there is stuff out there that's
very woke it's agenda driven I I you
know there's an agenda behind it and
that drives me crazy but there's always
there always has been that I think
propaganda movies and series and things
or writers are just having a agenda they
have a they have something they want to
say and it it overtakes the story but
anyway some people have said Ahsoka was
woke I can't I don't know why somebody
it's it's easy why to see why they would
call it that if you actually are
familiar with it at all or interested in
like where the the the stories go and
where the narrative is or anything like
it all makes sense like what's kind of
going on
but just from someone who's never seen
anything before and then they're going
for the first time it it doesn't matter
to me but there there are only female
protagonist really and Ezra the only
male protagonist in the entire show
doesn't actually have any like he
doesn't make decisions for himself ever
he has decisions made for him and is
like all right I'm following along and
you don't really get to him till later I
I don't that that's that's perfectly
fine with me I have no issue with that
but coming in from like trying to be as
objective as possible it might feel
weird in that sense where like this dude
doesn't have any agency but everybody
else around them does I
guess I I don't know I'm I'm I'm one
things they say about woke though is
that when the women are like awesome and
the men look stupid there's nothing in
this exactly that didn't happen at all
like everybody was getting like shat on
essentially the entire time so the dude
she goes looking for is Ezra or Emily I
forget what his name was yes um he was
better at the force
than than the other chick
was yeah he's there going I don't need a
weapon sh all the way through I think
one of the pick up the Blaster but we'll
get there yeah I think one of the
biggest examples of production being
woke was there was a series of books
back in the 40s and 50s called Tom Swift
it was like a it was like a
science-driven um alternative to The
Hardy Boys it was kind of what it was
well the CW uh produced a series called
Tom Swift it lasted
about less than a season I think he was
canceled before the first season even
ran and And the tagline for Tom Swift
was Swagger is a
science and it was just it was just
um
agenda and that's all it was it was
someone's agenda it was agenda over
story and I think agenda over story is
probably one the foundations of
something being legitimately woke like
you are saying Jamie I mean and because
it it was just terrible but you know I'm
for the life of me Ahsoka just were
there it was the issue that the night
witches weren't mean
enough well I mean you know were they
not evil enough was that the the the
reason why people charged a sooka and
still charged a sooka to this day as
being woke
propaganda uh was it because of as a
girl was it was it because that uh
Anakin got seen as in more of an
understandable human
light yeah he came across as a bit of a
hippie um secondly wks asked this
question a couple of times that's only
be fair um Thorn and Ezra had been in
the Galaxy for 12 years and accomplish
nothing didn't Thorne have to rebuild
this Star Destroyer well I think that
was the the reason literally like the
biggest exensions on the back of the
Star Destroyer were
still like one was missing and one was
smashed he was only capable of that slow
uh atmospheric flight he couldn't get up
into space that's why they had to bring
the I sign no no no no no he he he came
up from space he was literally stationed
on another planet that was not peridia
and that's why he wasn't there
immediately he had to leave that planet
he was at to go to peridia he wasn't
capable of hyperspace travel but the
ship anyway which is why I I I'm with
you secular monk as someone who has
followed deon's writing and his his
style of writing my entire
life it just wasn't there where where
this guy's been the best Easter egg
layer he's he's the freaking Easter
Bunny this Dave filon like this dude
just drops an egg
everywhere these are not the characters
that we are familiar with and sorry go
no sorry they're just I they're not
necessarily bastardized versions of the
characters that we're familiar with but
they're like I mentioned on Chillin
stream yesterday I saw a really funny
meme that was just talking about Thon it
was like Thon from the original Zan
Trilogy was like a three tier chess set
and then Thon from the Canon Trilogy is
just a normal chess set Thon from the
rebel show is a Checker's board and then
thrawn from Ahsoka is tic-tac-toe like
and that's what it felt like is like
this guy's so much more brilliant than
he is he there's no way you're telling
me he's spent half a decade or a decade
is it five years or 11 years I don't
really remember the exact time it's
about 10 years but yeah if they've been
there for a
decade it just seems like they were
waiting the whole time I I there are a
lot of thousands of caskets or whatever
the hell they're putting on the big ifs
on but why wouldn't why wouldn't what
what I mean there are a lot of questions
to be asked same thing like here uh we
were talking in the chat just a minute
ago how how did the night scissors never
find Ezra if if they can sense Ahsoka
coming in from a purle halfway across
the Galaxy there there's
there are nonsensical aspects that you
include one thing and it negates another
that happens over and over in the series
and that that doesn't happen in Star
Wars It's So meticulous and Dave has
always been so meticulous and it just
seems so lack of daac cool this time it
it hurts from someone who like loves
this and and and I don't want to nitpick
it but this is this is my Star Trek
moment with you and you and Mark
Jamie I I like the condition of the Star
Destroyer as like where he's at I mean
it's just apparently there's he has very
limited access to manufacturing you know
and um would he rather try to conquer
this galaxy he's in on his own with a
broken Star Destroyer or would he rather
come back to where he has you know Fleet
support with whatever is left over from
the Empire well of course but after half
a year of sitting there you're gonna do
something you're not going to wait for a
decade like dude's just been eating and
gaining a couple pounds for a decade is
that what's going on
maybe the Army he's seeking had to be
managed or maybe that's what they're
loading into is the night witch
zombies the only resources he had to
deal with were what came with him and
then you throw in all the damage all the
finite resources you can't you can't
just dick around for 10 years when you
literally have one ship and a crap done
of you know mostly half dead Storm
Troopers there's not a whole lot you can
do that planet was a waste planned there
there's no factories on that thing for
him to Parts there's none of
that thank you so much for the Super
Chat th uh yeah thraw didn't really seem
bothered by Ezra he seemed he seemed
bothered by Ahsoka and then he seemed
very b b and he kept saying one Jedi can
mess everything up but he really didn't
seem bothered by Ezra and I did love it
when they do the big reveal of Ezra and
they went and I said ah it's a bloke
with a beard and that was not a
clue Jedi would make thraw scared it
would be the one kid that thwarted him
Ahsoka wasn't able to thwart him like
Ezra was the only individual that
thwarted him and he's the only guy that
could keep him from going back to that
Galaxy he wants to go back to there's no
reason for him to just let Ezra be it's
it's a huge massive plot hole and it it
it leads like I I understand what y'all
are saying with like it he would have
been struggling to re
make the the Empire of the hand or or
whatever he's trying to do build his
troops but he's been there a decade a
decade he's traveling from one planet to
another there are Bandits across this
place if sh just somewhere and going I
raise my sword you're now part of my
team thron's a military genius he would
not be losing numbers or anything like
that he he'd be recruiting he'd be
actively trying to bring make the um the
Troopers keep their uniforms a bit
cleaner as well that's why they're
supposed to look all war it's like
General he's pretty clean how come all
the Storm Troopers are running around
with [__] up
uniforms that's that's another thing it
just feels like another character than
what he was even in Rebels we saw that
also in Mandalorian their uh the St the
the Stormtrooper outfits were not you
know their armor was scuffed it was not
in top condition yeah supposed to show
Decay over time and blah blah blah um
is it fair to say that this was supposed
to be a series for the really hardcore
Star Wars fans that have watched all the
animation and watched all those other
things in that case and it just
missed partially yeah I I talked about
this last night towards the end of the
stream I my feeling is that
Dave understands the situation that the
IP itself is in like all the brand
damage that's been done over the last
couple years and I feel like he made
this show for the hardcore Star Wars
fans because Star Wars isn't going to
get fixed without bringing the core back
in and then we'll bring the normies in
after we're all happy which is basically
how it's done anyway you get your
hardcore fans you get them happy you get
them talking and they'll bring the
normies along it's exactly what happened
with the
MCU yeah but it just didn't work fans
like holy crap this shit's dope and then
they started talking to everybody about
it and then poof Infinity I think that
was the idea with the sooka and then the
studio came in and said death too much
maybe and dragged him back yeah I think
F was like we're gonna make it something
for the the the Big Star Wars folk and
then the studio was like well we should
be able to advertise this to everybody
and and you should be able to uh but I
do like what Scotty was saying yesterday
in the chilling uh chilling stream was
this guy was saying like yes it it is
nice to have like all these different
like when you jump into a franchise from
any different point you should be able
to jump in there and and still enjoy
where you're at where Star Wars may it
it Star Wars if there is a franchise
that has gotten away from that and you
have to do homework it probably is Star
Wars it probably
is well Star Trek's the same to be hon
right so talking about toxic fan base
was going to say I think there's a
there's a line between I I get tired I
get called a toxic fanic cas and I
actually get accused on the channel
occasion so so negative and there's a
difference between being toxic and
actually not liking something and saying
so I firmly believe if if I I'm a treky
I love Star Trek when Stargate comes
back if I don't like it I'm gonna say
so um and but I'll say why I won't just
go this is a great pile of crap and blah
blah blah I'll say look I don't like
this I don't um and I'll look for the
positive
though well it's like seemingly sorry
why are fans seemingly so angry at the
moment at everything stormy yeah you
know I really don't know unless that's
they just get off on it you know because
it's um I saw this one
tweet from unfortunately somebody I know
that listed all like a big laundry list
of um shows that had gone woke and it
list the things that and you read
through the comments it's like that's
not woke we did you get no that's just
you know and it was just one after the
other then there's this big hate Fest in
the comments about this show wasn't woke
I love this show how dare you you know
and they even I think they actually you
know mentioned fireflies being woke like
how the [__] fireflies the antio if
anything mil misogynist really and and
so you know like let's say you would um
there's something about Stargate you
know coming up that you wouldn't like
you're not spending
you know uh the preceding six months
bashing it
online you you you know you're reporting
on it well this is what we've heard and
this is what we hope and this will be
good and we can't wait you know which
should we see the reboot of a universe
should we see the reboot of you know
these are the questions we're asking
we're not coming right off the the bat
saying oh it's going to
suck because it's MGM it's just you know
we're not taking a position that it is
going going to suck before we' SE before
the first word's been written before the
first Poster's been issued before we
even know who the cast is you know and I
think that's the difference you were
talking about honest critique film
critique and the other is just you know
troll outlandish bad behavior with
people that may not be good actors I
mean actors in terms of a strategy not a
lot
of what do you think Harris part of the
problem with that though is the studio o
PR departments aren't helping they're
not differentiating between that loud
annoying dumbass full of
[__] people
crowd and the rest of us who are just
like no we like your product but you
know these are the flaws in it and we're
trying to let you know so you can
[__] fix
it problem is most a lot of PR
departments especially Lucas film
they're like literally the worst about
this that I've seen is they just take
that broad brush and any criticism oh
nope you're all those crazy
people and thly those of us who are
obviously not get really freaking
annoyed about
it yeah yeah makes a perfect action I I
have a psychology background I think I'm
sure I've mentioned that before but so
I've counseling um psychological
assessments and things like this and
um part of that is you're looking for
certain markers and people's
personalities and particularly when you
something called CBT I don't know if I
don't know if the American is the same
it's cognitive behavioral therapy and
and yes I watch some of these guys and
I'm like oh there I i' you know oh this
this would be several sessions of
counseling watch some with these guys I
like yeah it is it does say a lot more
about them it
does Point here it's going to suck
because it's
Amazon it's not personally what he
thinks but it's what people say and it's
true what what do you think Harris
uh I mean Ju Just to kind of uh pick up
where Aaron was was saying a second ago
because we did discuss this little
of the pr departments for all these
different companies have to do a better
job if if all you do is say these fans
are good so we're gonna put them in the
the spotlight these fans are bad so
we're going to pretend like they don't
exist that's that's not a conversation
and if there's no conversation being
directed from the actual PR department
at all and it's just like no YouTube
comments no dislike button no nothing
like that the loudest person in the room
will always be the angriest person in
the back and that's what's happened over
the last few years
and it's it's where we're at no matter
what franchise we're talking about
someone's gonna be pissed off about
something and that's because these PR
departments aren't actively I'm not
saying go take control back of the
conversation but at least spearhead the
conversation at least at least lead the
charge and say well this is kind of what
we're going to be doing for the next
couple years or hey this is like a fun
little like even whenever like it's an
anniversary of something Lucas film
still has the comments off
like that's bad if if you have people
still [__] on the prequels or
[__] on the o OT like whatever it
may be like that that conversation's
there that doesn't mean take it away you
know um is like look at the end of the
day though man as as a
YouTuber which I still find it weird to
oh I'm an influencer sorry I'm an
influencer now I forgot to mention that
oh wow congratulations on no um but yes
I influence ones of people all the
time yeah I I just wonder though he's
hating on something and and being
negative about something isn't it more
interesting than being nice look at the
end of the day we watch it so poop we
don't watch it for everyone going oh I
love you man come here this a big hug we
watch it for the you screwed my
husband's second cousin and then I there
we watch for the drama don't we and the
negativity is more interesting it's
wrong it's it's a crap sense of human
beings really that we find that sort of
stuff the news they tried to do a good a
good news story at the end don't they it
doesn't work no one cares and and today
a puppy was safe from a tree did the
puppy then fall and like Maul somebody
no no no it just went home the puppy
didn't Maul anyone no it's just it was a
happy ending off you know I mean
it's
it's one of the oldest things in
journalism if it bleeds it leads yeah
Y and it's disappointing but it's it's
the way Humanity
works it just I'm with you it just
doesn't help that these departments are
cutting off a portion of that that fan
base which which makes them that much
louder and angrier like hey well they're
not going to like even want us to talk
anymore there's only the only thing we
can do is be angry now and and that's
just kind of what we keep seeing I feel
like the puppy
was which which puppy which does it
matter which puppy all the puppies all
the all the puppies we've got a problem
puppies are all loved so therefore
they're woke yeah we got a problem
recently in dogs you know you like you
have school shootings we have dogs that
keep eating people it's happened a
couple of times like really recently um
so have you heard of Barbie Thor
power the biggest movie of the entire
freaking year Barbie go broke is
complete
[__] forget that phrase see it it's
garbage I just see um for
me I I honestly do think there has been
a massive overcorrection by a lot of
filmmakers writers directors and Studios
Studios are terrified being called
racist or homophobic or whatever else so
they've massively overcorrected and I I
and I yeah I'm with you on that we get
films like Ghostbusters with boobs and
you just go this is this is just a bunch
of really angry women this doesn't seem
there's no film here where's the film G
I still haven't seen that movie I still
haven't seen it's it it's the writing
it's always just the writing or the
conception it's a technical thing if if
a movie studio or director or
screenwriter makes the mistake of
putting agenda before story quality yeah
but that's still a writing thing I know
I'm not always sure because Executives
do get involved in these things and
there are look at the end of the day the
Studios have been hiring equality
Executives the last few years and they
seem to be getting rid of them again
don't they
but either way it's it's still a
technical aspect of the of the process
it's it's pressure from executive at at
at its most basic
level it's I yeah from the writing I
think there's two issues with the
writing there's too much TV because of
the streaming Wars and there's too much
writing and it's been watered down the
quality's been watered down and
Executives I think there are putting
pressure on writers to go have you
mentioned this demographic have you
mentioned this demographic don't forget
to talk about this and it forces writers
to go in a certain way that they don't
necessarily always want to going there
are also a lot of
writers well there are also a lot of
writers out there that are going you
know what I'm sick that racism in this
country is [__] a nightmare and I'm
going to talk about it um and I can't
argue with them for that I can't I can't
blame them it does seem to be in America
particularly and parts of Europe are
massively diverse are massively
divided and it's people are angry yeah
well it's it just goes down to the
delivery in the execution like look at
the spiderverse
movies there are so many things about
those movies that like the hardcore
reactionaries would be like just
screaming their heads off about but you
barely saw anything about those movies I
mean like the ultra Hardcore people were
crying but even they were an extreme
minority of their extreme minority those
there's plenty of stuff in those movies
but those movies hit and they made a
crap ton of money for what they were
because they delivered on it correctly
they weren't preachy that's the problem
when writers or Studios or execs get
preachy the message you're you know
you're done people
just if it's preachy or there's
literally just no substance and you can
tell that an executive came in there
just to tick a box that's whenever it it
be it doesn't become hard to watch but
you as an audience member just you
recognize it and it's just there and
you're like that doesn't feel right and
and if it doesn't feel right it
shouldn't be in the show if you have
something with substance to add please
add it please add it like spider vers is
the the epitome of that example like
tick every box you freaking feel like
there's every kind of Spider-Man you can
even imagine and then some yeah I mean
Tom Smith double checked it was horrible
yeah if it has substance put it in there
please do and and let different people
be represented do all that stuff but
have have substance or it negates the
purpose in general it makes the meaning
lesser it makes putting things in new
things after that lesser it it just it
hurts it overall just substance please
substance substance can I say it again
makes people
watch wait please thank you one sec um
people are voting with their eyeballs
SPID loads and loads of people watch
spider be fair was massively popular
yeah like five what was it five six
hundred million at the box office for an
animated movie everybody watched that
movie everybody so but you could argue
that a lot of Disney is failing a lot of
Marvel is failing y but I would argue is
because they weren't very good the
Marvel movies four or five have been
horribly bad
movies and I I watched love and thunder
again the other day just thought it
can't be as bad as I remember let's give
it the go and it is
it's were you closer to
a the goats killed it for me I I just I
heard those words and I just didn't want
to listen to about that I hate that
movie I
literally hate hate that movie quantam
Mania is almost right there too like
those two switch spots for me every once
in a while but those movies were awful
Quantum man's got else is messed up
about get involved in this stuff the
people they're trying to help get
screwed over even more they're not
helping they're doing a disservice to
those communities and they put out
garbage and trying they're trying to put
out a message in garbage and that's not
going to work not only you going to piss
off the ones that always cry about it
you're hurting the communities you're
trying to
help yeah like
completely much much much worse it's
it's awful and space goats no go on
just was it was cool it was funny the
first half dozen times but you
know but Al so I watched I finished off
a secret
Invasion and it
was that's that's the best reaction I
think I've seen on the entire interwebs
right
there
stor Samuel Jackson is no slacking he's
not a slacker actor he's really good and
yeah they didn't use him you know and I
I forget the guy's name he played
krennic I think on um Rogue one he play
uh uh yeah you know it's you know who
I'm talking about remind me really great
actor Ben mindon sorry yes yes yes yes
thank you they didn't use him they
didn't they the the writing got nowhere
near their acting skills and it was just
tragic to watch
Ben melon Kobe smolders and Amilia Clark
were criminally criminally
underutilized I mean that you know so
when you're talking about you know the
the wokeness or the the whatever it was
man the you know are they just not
getting top tier writers for these guys
I mean Samuel L Jackson is [__]
golden and it was
just I don't know that that
said Here Comes something really
controversial uh
oh I watched the first episode of Loki
last night I've not watch seen it loved
it ah no no that's that's what most
people are saying yeah so I mean it was
there the writing was exceptional I
thought and it really and it and you can
just tell that the actors really brought
the those words out and it was it was
night now it's a Marvel thing I get that
but it was night and day from Secret
invasion you know can't wait to watch it
in that case I love the first season I
thought it was fantastic um I thought I
thought it was brilliant I thought it
set up and started to set up what was
coming so well and then the movies
flushed it down the
toilet really really quickly yeah um
Quantum Mania flush down toilet yeah
Quantum flush yeah Quantum flush
straight down the low
but great I cannot wait for Loki
thens oh dude so good cool cool I'm
looking forward to that um my main
problem as well with um secret invasion
was it made no logical
sense um they basically did things like
apparently they were going around
swabbing all the DNA for the blood to
make all these stupid things that's not
how DNA works or blood or
science um it's it's just it was just
stupid um and that's what annoys me it
was like shehulk where you watch it and
like go this is just stupid it doesn't
it's it doesn't make any sense to the
point of actually like insulting me that
I'm sitting and watching it that how
thick do you think I am that I'm
watching this and thinking yeah
brilliant this this isn't this isn't me
like separating in fantasy and just
enjoying the fantasy of it and like
ignoring certain things that you know
aren't really science or you know what I
mean or in fantasy where oh was going to
use space whales space whales space
whales I can even let space whales go at
least it's not at least it's not
insulting um you know I mean but I find
I found secret Invasion
insulting going this is just stupid that
that thank you again for the
contribution secret invasion was should
have stayed a
secret yes Melvin you are coming back so
you always got the best comments in the
thing um it should have been it was just
awful
okay W with I think Melvin Quest just
said something in there that was perfect
a couple minutes ago first though the
only person that did that that did not
phone in a performance and actually had
something good in secret evasion was
Olivia Coleman she's the only person
that showed up to work the only
individual that showed up to work the
entire time and the last episode is
might be one of the worst episodes of
Television I think I've ever witnessed
but welcome to she was I think she was
the star of the show she took whatever
shitty line she had and she made it
resonate man which was great oh my God
last episode was God awful and I I think
sci-fi Quest Melvin was he he just he
scrolled up a little bit too many
writers that want to write their own
things is definitely a huge issue and
that's one of the big things that was
going on with the riters room and the
riter strike right now which I I I think
I don't I don't remember the exact
riters room minimum that they uh set on
I I need to look at what actually like
was agreed upon but that was one of the
big things and I was not with the
writers on that side at all because the
writers wanted to have at least six
people in a writers room six different
people have six different ideas and and
and one of the most popular television
show on planet Earth at the moment is
Yellowstone which is written by one guy
the prequel series both of them written
by one guy it's true he's done multiple
movies during all this time one guy he
has a vision and I think I I I I think
doing the writers room it sounds good to
keep jobs and stuff but it makes us it
it continues the Marvel and it continues
what Disney is doing right now Disney
has large uh Riders rooms and we've seen
what happens when they do instead of
Step Marcus Christopher mcely having the
two of them writing the next Avengers
movie or the next Captain America movie
it's not one or two people doing it
anymore it's a whole assembly of people
and and then nobody's Point ever gets
across that's why it feels like one
episode might be going one way the one
might be going another way and then it's
not like a succinct story that's like
leading you somewhere I think that's one
of the issues with ahoka as well when
they used to do 22 Episodes of a season
though they would have a writers room
they would have a team of six or seven
writers on on a series and they'd have
meetings they'd have meetings at the
start and they would figure out General
tone and story arc and blah blah but
then generally speaking a person would
write an episode and then it would maybe
go to Brandon brager or something who
would then work with it with him and
rewrite a bit here and then go okay
brilliant I love this because he
actually said there was very few he was
saying like Ronald D Moore was one of
the very few times he got a script and
just went perfect
yeah man I was GNA just get ready to
because the way he did U manage the
writing room in for Battle Star
Galactica was he had very few people he
hired the writers that he trusted to
Nate go do this episode okay this is
where we're going you to all get
together this is the drunk this is what
we're going to do this is the U story
path we're going for go for it yeah and
then they would come together apparently
there's all certain writers as well
would have they would be like they would
have a character that was theirs and
then they would so then you would refer
to what what do you think if it St
treking what you think data would do in
this scenario and that that that person
was supposed to be and the idea being
that through the
series it kept a it kept a a voice for
the actor so I quite like that idea it
feel it feels a bit bit managed but it
was it was a good idea to go well I
would write it like this and you know
but the WR whoever was writing the
script still had the the the final say
but there was that person you'd go to
you know to like go how did he say this
how' he do that I like that but now
again yeah it seems to be that it's by
committee and you can always tell when a
movie has gone mental because there'll
be an executive and stories come they
all the stories always come out
eventually but there was some EXE itive
somewhere putting pressure on the writer
to do something that they had to then
shoe horn in or go a certain way um that
movie Wild Wild West remember that and
apparently the producer just as as a
thing for spiders so just well he wanted
to put it in another movie five years
before then and then was like well where
can I put this we're gonna put it here
and just decided because he was like one
of the executives and was like I can do
this now yeah like Kevin Smith talked
about how he was writing a um Superman
movie and I can't remember the
producer's name but the producer name
could go in and I love that I love this
idea I love it and and Kevin Smith had
written the script for it I'd love this
I'd love him though to fight a giant
spider and and then then two years later
we got Wa West andin yeah that
was hey but we finally did
getage Superman fighting spider giant
spiders it's jollywood that's why he
fighting giant spiders than in Flash
because it's a joke in Hollywood that
this guy was obsessed um but anyway well
yeah so you know it's like the thing I
like going back to the toxic environment
on Twitter on social media is Tana M uh
masania maslana Ted
ml mlan mlan thank you thank you thank
you she gets all the blame for the bad
writing and the bad executive decisions
yeah you know they always take it out on
her you
know she's to blame for that as well who
did the terrible parking she's to blame
for that as well bloody thing I
thought parking even looking over the
the whole fourth you know pain being
broken and all that you know I thought
she did a very good job but it was the
be the best part of She-Hulk was Tom
Ruffalo you know I mean Mar RL excuse me
She-Hulk wasn't badly written I don't
think it was badly written I think it
was badly conceived in the first place
oh the whole idea of the series was a
bad idea the whole idea was we're going
to do what we did in the comics a couple
of times we're going to do this whole
story and then we're going to break the
fourth wall and we're going to go and
see Kevin F and we're going to go
punching this things because that's what
we used to do in the comics occasionally
and not all of the shehulk comics by the
way just some of them but and and we're
going to do that and that was badly
conceived from the
beginning um that we made a mistake in
my in my opinion because you do you
think it would have worked better as a
film no like in a vein of a Deadpool but
She-Hulk problem is She-Hulk Deadpool
doesn't unravel everything at the end
Deadpool he breaks the fourth wall
because that I mean that's been done for
years years ago a Christian Slater and
things like that break the fourth wall
talk to the camera if you do it if you
do it sparingly it's really really funny
and really good and Deadpool does it
brilliantly mentioning Patrick Stewart
and you know things like this just very
throwaway comments brilliant there are
moments versus She-Hulk where she just
like Conant but also the worst thing She
Hulk did though is he she set up the
whole thing was set up all these
villains and all this story and trying
to get her blood and all this stuff and
they just took it all apart in the end
and get the end of the episode and go
whoa so everything that happened in
every other
episode didn't I either didn't happen or
was a compl
time because she just goes ah I don't
like that I'm going to do this ending
instead oh I don't like that I'm gonna
do this ending instead and I'm just like
you made it all
pointless that's the problem a very bad
attempt at
meta well yeah which just didn't
work there was a there was another show
that was really leaned into the fourth
pain
thing one sci-fi it was oh god
um uh Kevin
spacy House of Cards House of Cards did
it oh yeah he kept talking to camera at
the end of like youd like have a
conversation with a politician and look
at the camera and explain what his
thought processes is how he's gonna [__]
this guy over or stab this dude in the
back or whatever they did that a lot and
I think the first or second season I
can't recall them doing a lot in the
third mostly the first season and then I
think they they stepped away from it a
little bit because they didn't want it
to be a comedy show so they made it more
serious
they treated that more like a narration
though and that felt okay it was like a
fourth wall narration but it was like
those moments were
like e Exposition that got you inside of
his brain and not necessarily like quips
or jokes or but everything that he did
pushed the story along in that which
made it feel more narrative based I
guess first two seasons if house of
cards were amazing oh the first couple
of
Seasons right
crazy sorry who was that I said crazy
plays crazy well that's true um just one
last thing on the on the on the toxic
fandom then because I mean we have this
a lot of Star Trek as well and that's my
that's more my fandom a lot of division
a lot of unhappiness about the way Star
Trek has gone in the last few years and
a lot of anger because people genuinely
feel like their favorite show has been
took away from
them is it a problem or is it just
society and we should just let it slide
or is it something that we should
Challenge and you know should thing or
is it just you don't like something say
you don't like it and really move on
does it matter stormy does does it
matter
um my con again my concern is with all
the toxic behavior is people are um uh
coming out against things when they have
no knowledge of it now it's been going
on forever they used to do this with
books you know remember when Robert
Jordan you know when before the Lord of
chaos came out I mean it was just oh my
God it's going to be the suckiest ass
thing ever you know but that was just
bitching on AOL that's how far back that
goes um but I think the
um it is unfair when you do have
something that's quality like um I was
talking about earlier the the shows of
gone woke you know one that that they
had mentioned was lower decks which I
thought was just lower decks was
insanely brilliant very entertaining
very I mean it's the Easter egg Easter
edgiest thing that ever you know the TNG
yeah but you know it's um you know they
do have some lesbian characters and
things like that and stuff but that's
just they're not all of it though and
they don't they don't it doesn't like
some of the arguments for Discovery is
that it seems like some of the
characters are I'm a lesbian yeah but
what else is about you go no I'm a
lesbian goes yes but have you got
anything else interested about you at
all um I like girls no that's not what
we mean um you know it's just like
there's been but that's not lower decks
no at all you know but still that's
where we're at and I think it's very
unfair to the writers that do produce
good material like lower decks and the
actors on Lower decks and then these
other these other things that are
considered you know that that whatever
reason the mob uh goes after you know
the whole thing it reminds me of the
plot in this movie
Agora with Rachel y it's just if you
haven't seen Agora go out and the the
people
that I don't want to give any way
spoilers with the people that the bad
guys these are the movie trolls that you
see in this
movie and I did love how shehulk poked
bear I wish they just done that once
again that was another problem with she
they did it too many times like you said
earlier stormy too many times the four
they poked the bear of Twitter and I
loved it the first time I thought that's
brilliant but then they did it again and
again move
there's always Instagram or Facebook
yeah Aaron what do you think man is this
something we should worry about or is it
or should we just let it
go people want to be negative let them
be [__]
negative I mean I the way I personally
roll as I give credit where it's to do
and if it you make it messed up I'm G
freaking talk about that too like if
it's good I'll praise it if it's not
I'll [__] on it it's just you know the
way it is the problem with what's going
on in the ROMs is PE some people either
hate a thing just because of who made it
like for example there's you know
there's a whole group of people that are
so so against Disney that even before a
show comes out and it's not just Marvel
or not just Star Wars It's Marvel too I
see it online all the time it's like
they're just automatically saying
because Disney made it it's going to be
woke and they automatically hate
it Umstead of actually you know going on
a case- by case basis like normal
people
so exactly I mean it's you can you can
try and ignore it and you can or you can
attempt to engage him I attempt to
engage him
it's you're
bra yeah it's waste of time I've tried
once or twice you know just back fires
but goes in the face I mean sometimes I
get bored enough and I go and I go out
and be like whatever but as soon as I
mean as long as long as these Studios
actually start to put quality first
they the the ability of those people to
like they'll they'll actually start to
be ignored by people on a much more wide
basis I think but we got to get the
quality back up in
everything that that's the primary thing
if we get quality those people can be
ignored although I will say just as bad
as those who hate something like we just
use Disney just as bad as the people
that hate something just because Disney
makes it are the people on the other
side that are automa like oh it's a
Disney thing I love it you must love it
too and if you don't you're toxic and
you're an IST and you're a phobe it's
like no it was good it's good if it's
not it's not it's just because Lucas
film makes something doesn't
automatically make it good or bad it's a
case- by case thing and neither side of
the neither extreme end of the phandom
is willing to budge on that instead of
just
being yeah there's a meme in Star Trek
and it's um Dr Basher and the character
whose name I forgotten oh crap he was
one of the best ones as
well dck dck um and they're saying yeah
do I like All Star Trek and he goes even
the Star Trek I don't like and his gu
say especially the Star Trek you don't
like and I'm like no some Star Trek I
don't like and I am allowed to say I
don't like it and that doesn't make me
toxic it doesn't make me a bloody troll
because I'm not there going this is
thing and this this character's crap
because of then I hate and I'm not
getting overly aggressive I remember
it's a t show but I don't like it Harris
what do you think man like say should we
engage these people
or uh I
mean it is part of the conversation I I
think the points maybe brought up should
be talked about but I don't know if
engaging with the people and
indulging
indulging I don't like the word toxic
toxic or woke I don't like either one of
those words they're just way both
overused
nowadays um but I I I don't don't
indulge the toxicity per se but talk
about the points uh and and try to find
uh the intelligent conversation
somewhere in between them if
possible I
me that little G will be biting me later
I don't want it to live so I you know
instead of engaging these guys I think
we should do what we're doing here you
know we talk about you know we do you
know legit art criticis ISM you know
we're we're not you know preloading
something that's come out that we not
seen you know with negative thoughts or
whatever we're not promoting stuff that
uh we're not saying Something's Gonna Be
Awesome when we've never seen it you
know I think you know instead of D you
know engaging the the hate
trolls just you know produce content
that's reasonable that's legitimate and
I think that goes farther because if you
get into the hate troll fight the the
hate trolls going to win because he's
just that's just he just wants to wear
you down it's Justa it's only he's he's
pewing but what we're doing is actually
doing something that's honest and legit
I think that's the best step to fighting
that not engaging them but outdoing them
if that makes so you're saying sometimes
it's just better to keep it simple
stupid there we go my life in
general my favorite s in the world
stupid keep it simple yeah we'll lead by
example we are a shining beacon in the
world of on how to do this positively
and do it
right please don't that's that's a lot
of pressure man that's a lot of pressure
um but um yeah I I think I I think we go
into this doing this whole YouTube thing
honestly and just be honest if you don't
like something just say you don't like I
I've I've seen I have critiqued stuff
that I've not seen yet but it's been in
like I don't I don't think he's the
right person for this role I I can't see
it then you when you watch it you either
go I was right or you go no I was wrong
he was amazing and that you know honesty
I think we've done that a couple of
times where we'll talk about something
and we go don't know about this but then
I think we're brilliant in that we then
stand and go we were wrong I know I have
anyway I I was bang wrong that was
phenomenal and you know and and I think
some people are afraid to be
wrong whereas I um again as I'm married
I'm used to being wrong so apparently
every everything I say pretty much so
it's it's okay to be
wrong and but I watch I there's a few
YouTube channels that I've watched
because they and I've had to block them
um I won't name them that's not fair but
I've had to block them in there because
even though they talk about some really
interesting things
sometimes they come at everything from a
negative perspective and everything has
to be a shocking
um you know title or whatever and even
if then what they actually say isn't
that they have to come at it from that
perspective and I just can't watch it
it's um it's just it's just dis just
disappointing but that's just me I I'm a
silver lining kind of guy what can you
do and we bring in people here that
are but guys right thank you so much and
I'm
glad did we actually enjoy a sooka then
I I quite
enjoyed oh yeah lik very much liked it
but you were disappointed by it I'd give
it a solid six six and a half I maybe
enjoyed it more because I didn't know
all the all you this is this is viewed
like when I watched the JJ from Star
Trek and if somebody doesn't like Star
Trek when in they'd be like great what
what a Marvel's movie quite a lot of
lens flares I like a lens flare and
but as a treky I'm going into it going
what's wrong with the warp core why is
the warp core stupid and you know like
and things like that what's the flappy
things on this on the Enterprise the
Enterprise doesn't got flappy things and
you know I'm like nickp picking and is
that fair to say with you Harris with
with this episode that you just like
it's the detail that they maybe
M or the lack thereof
yeah that's really what it is because
like I said I guess earlier Dave's been
the Easter Bunny for years now it was
just I don't know there were two or
three threads here where usually there
are two or three major threads and about
12 or 14 little Sub sub like minor
outling threads that are there to pick
up from as well and there was just
nothing like that and that kind of stuff
really helps you live in the world that
you're watching and it didn't feel like
we could live in the world that we were
watching this entire time it felt like
we were just strictly viewers and where
episode six helped that episode five and
six that World building aspect of those
two episodes really kind of brought that
back and I was like this is going to end
super well and then we got episode seven
and eight and and they weren't bad there
were great great great bits in both
episodes but neither of them had
narrative purpose they were just they
didn't even finish off what we thought
was going on with this series it it
there wasn't even a technical
Cliffhanger we just
stopped it's it's
weird end was weird the end was weird
right before we go I have sort of
announced this through um the Community
page and on Facebook I think but next
week um the we are appearing on the
companion with Brad Wright so we are
quite excited it will be me and Matthew
as long as he's better um otherwise
Harris you're the first substitute mate
so I mean stormy you're always free I'm
working all the damn time
I'm not yeah but I mean yeah being a
rocket scientist I know it's it'll be
next Saturday at 5:00 pm UK time we
think we're going to be able to stream
it live here as well but we're not 100%
certain because Harris has been told
that but I haven't and citrek is my
channel and I don't know what's going on
yet what they announced gu the end of
the companion yesterday yeah well I'll
find out tomorrow maybe because we're
having a a video chat conference call to
discuss it so um but we're going to be
um to Brad right um there is a a me
there is a little thing on the Community
page if you want to throw in your
question
ideas um please do I'm thinking we might
do like a fast um you know like a many
questions getting in 60 seconds at the
end it's a bit of a fun thing so try to
test Brad Wright's knowledge what I was
thinking was I might do quotes is it
Stargate or um Travelers or something
like that maybe and try to see if he can
um guess you know like silly little game
or something but if anybody's got any
IDE is we've got 15 minutes with Brad
Wright 15 minutes so we need to make
sure that we don't waste it so because
we'll probably never get it again we
will be appearing with dial the gate and
gate World um and um so we' got some
bridges to BU build there yeah once he
figures out who we are that's that's the
last we see of Brad
Wright Brad Wright loves me I was about
to say he's been texting Jamie somehow
we're we're we're in there well there
yeah he's desperate huh my friend um
Jamie wakes up in the mornings and says
good morning Brad like the first thing
he does when he texts and then he says
can
night um but but it's it's not um but
but yeah it's it's going to be very cool
um it's it really is a celebration of
Stargate and that's the point that's
guys I want you to be involved I want
your questions throw them in um
patreon and channel members I'm going to
pick one question from you guys you get
you get a question um so please any
ideas but it's going to be very exciting
then we will be back Sunday as normal um
and
um yeah just we're GNA enjoy it screw it
and then we're that close to a Stargate
announcement I just to tell that um I
was given a little bit of info basically
to say that um MGM have now started to
consider sort of like bringing in a
couple of um of the original producers
and adal makers so Brad Ry Joseph MOSI
things like this not to appear or not to
do anything creative just to sort of
like um consult them on their decision
before um it's released basically before
it's announced they want to try they're
trying to get some positive voices from
the original series so that again just
scream seems to me that they're doing a
continuation rather than a full reboot
because if they're doing a they pretty
much confirm that anyway but um it's
it's nice to know they're actually
thinking they might do that so let's
hope they do because Brad right deserves
at least a phone call for [__] sake
something it do a text message a
WhatsApp do a WhatsApp group as long as
they don't Peter Jackson and you
know yeah
well I
mean it is
Amazon oh yes so we will see you all
next week um have a great week everybody
enjoy this incredibly warm weather I
don't know what it's like over there but
it's Autumn here it's hot still 25
degrees centigrade and all the for you
it's bloody chilly where I'm
at not
here weirdly warm so anyway global
warming gotta love it um all came in and
smack Us in the face
yesterday well we haven't got it here so
anyway guys thank you so so much um
bye-bye everybody and we will see you
next week next week I gotta find the end
bit wait a second
[Music]
bye